Jason Emily you have seen each other
since Game of Thrones every time I come
to England
oh and in fact I just remembered so
because this goes out we're taping this
on a Thursday so this goes out tomorrow
night yes
so will you tomorrow night so when we
won't be here we'll be at my party it
will be us for a party you going do you
want to see I'd love to come as long as
just mystic and swap clothes and I turn
up first
[Applause]
Oh Ross is so
[Applause]
[Applause]
her Summerland Summerland yeah how do
you know that over here because we've
done research on my summer land was the
first TV show I was I can't believe talk
about the summer land was the first show
I ever was on and it was your first
that was my first onscreen kiss I think
it was like 16 so I was very nervous and
yes I still get nervous but I was very
nervous for this thing yeah it's all
about making I wanted to make her as
comfortable as possible she was 17 and
went in to go in for the kiss and
everyone's watching it's a closed set
even more awkward yeah like only special
people to watch yeah and everyone else
is on whatever her name was
Wow very hot embers the names of the
chimp Seaworth will
[Applause]
why poor her bill already I at lunch
they serve fish and I was I'm not you
know the the lunch spreads on set some
it can or any sense you've never seen
food like this I was like 17 I've never
seen like crab legs up for multiple
people movies right I've never seen it
was a catered lunch and my mom was
freaking out we've never seen this much
food it was insane so I just went to
town and I started eating I was doing
only guest spotting so I had crab it's a
man I had all this stuff and next was
the kissing scene and I was very nervous
and we went in for the kiss I got off
this close and all the sudden I yeah I
shut my eyes and I'm ready to go and
nothing happens I'm going further and
it's nothing's happening further like
thinking eventually we're gonna touch
and all of a sudden here oh my gosh did
you have salad for lunch
yeah and it ruined ruined Oh first yes
sorry I promise I brush my teeth I
learned a big lesson that day you do
carry a toothbrush with you everywhere
you go - I just had one I really just
had one back actually you know what I
don't know a full one but if anybody
wants it
I was doing a production in the West End
some years ago and it was very unusual
sort of production that the audience it
was a very different kind of audience
people would come in with take away food
and eat takeaway food people hen parties
become a blow-up dolls buying seats for
blow-up goals and and don't sleep lots
of people seem to be sort of fainting
and carried out on Gurney's but the most
spectacular all of these things is that
one night some people two people in the
balcony vomited - the people in the
circle four to six people
vomiting in the stalls was an amazing
night out of turn tickets now to
Midsummer Night - what did you for you
performed in a seafood festival I mean
what [ __ ] show you one know about was it
crap I thought I had a crab fest and a
beginning to stand-up comedy you're not
you're not performing in in luxury
you know venues that whoever they feel
they can build the stage and make money
as where you going so there was a crab
fest comedians talent people cracking
prayer
[Laughter]
[Applause]
literally the frustration that comes
from not being able to open a crack
you're not funny at the same time that
you hear I remember hearing a woman's
older lady who was like she was cracking
crack
cuz this how you Craig Craig tell a joke
and a joke doesn't work and I remember
this lady just gonna be booze
disappointment her voice she said baby
it was I oh no baby mistake
with my choice of life wrong you know
look at the the hardship that I went
through his help helped build me into
the person I am today right I can take
so much but I've been through it all I
was I was hit in the face with a buffalo
wing there's no food
it was it was a it was actually a male
strip club they shut down for comedy for
the first half I'm sure it was ladies in
there and you know it's just supposed to
be us performing for these women that
were roused up first I got on stage when
they introduced me and as late as I pull
it out I say that's not me I'm here
entertained
I know who's got kids that stuff trying
to merge into kid material do from the
back he's like that's enough he does do
a buffalo wing sauce
I assumed it was a woman with a deep
voice I was like who throw it who if at
the end of that I'm a man I'm a man
first don't disrespect me he's stood up
like I did it not
I can't deplete it just taking my
clothes off
[Applause]
well you've also had a quite a classic
bad date yes I did when I find a couple
of them but one was really bad I was a
double date a buddy of mine and I went
out with two girls many years ago and
the girls didn't I think was pretty
quickly realized they were not that
interested in either one of us and we
thought it would be funny if we just
started making each other laugh and each
guy kept trying to outdo the other guy
with just silly things and when we were
driving home I was driving and I used to
have a jeep it didn't have the doors on
it or roof or anything like that and I
was driving I thought it'd be really
funny if while I was talking to my date
who was riding and the scene next to me
if I just stepped out I started running
alongside the car and I wasn't driving
fast obviously but even when you're
driving slow you can't it's really fast
she was talking some I just stepped out
of my car to run and I hit the pavement
so and I felt the tire kind of swoosh
past my house I looked up and I saw my
car going toward a tree it stopped
because the girl that backed had to jump
in the front seat and put on the
emergency brake my hands were all cut up
my hands were torn I limped back to the
car and they were ashen face and wonder
what what did and then we just drove
home very quiet
did you pretended to be in an accident
probably no I thought it'd be funny if
right honestly there's no explaining it
I would be funny if I remember my my leg
really hurt when I got home I used to
have contact lens contact lenses I had a
contact lens case and when I got home I
took off my pants and I saw the imprint
of left and right Ronen you also you
want a really good prize what did you
win I won a trip to Florida when I was a
kid ladies and gentlemen
tell us how you want it I will I worn it
when I was when I was a kid and I had
never entered into a competition like
that before and it was the first day of
the summer holidays when I was I was
like 9 or 10 or something and Jeri Ryan
who you know was this very well-known
Irish DJ at home he's passed away now
but he was really incredible and his
shell was like the top shell in the
country and Shrek 2 had just come out
that's how long ago was and he was given
away this holiday to Florida and what
you had to do was you had to phone in as
one of the characters and Shrek 2 and
tell Jerry why you deserved the holiday
and I haven't started properly acting
yet at that stage or anything dad was an
actor so it was around sir like you know
improvisers and things like that and I
was like you should go in first just why
not we had never been on like a proper
holiday God okay so we got a little
notepad like tiny little notepad and we
wrote down like a tiny little script of
what I was gonna say just the short
little script and they got on and I
think I was one of the first kids on and
I and I did it as the gingerbread man
and and so then five days later he he
found up and told me that well you were
on The Late Late back in Ireland
they found this clip so this is this is
two little clips put together this it's
your gingerbread man yeah followed by
which I read like your reaction to
winning is very squeaky voice now
Saoirse is 10 years of age now which
character of you chosen
[Music]
[Music]
girl in the house are you well I've got
news for you you're going to Florida
when you win an Oscar I want you to
react like that you are good at English
accents oh you are oh yeah that you have
a decent English like an etiquette you
think Chris could do well well one of
our most popular ones probably not very
politically correct so we'll do it
sounds a Taylor with a guy called Mark
Williams and we ste we were very over
familiar say hello sir
try that on Cillian hello sir hello sir
were you out with a lady last night sir
oh did you want it with a lady last
night sir was it a lady though sir
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you